citizens of the reject Nation this is my
non-spoiler across the spiderverse
review and I'm happy to say I think I
have a new favorite Spider-Man movie
which means I have a new top 10 comic
book movie and I think maybe even bigger
than that I've only ever given 22 films
five stars I think this is 23. across
the spider verse non-spoiler this
is somehow a bigger leap in what I think
animation technology is than even the
first one I don't I don't know animation
but the things I saw are just
mind-boggling with the accomplishments
and just visual aesthetic
notwithstanding the story is such an
accomplishment I felt so much for these
characters I love these characters
already and I love them even more now
and it trusts the audience to have a
drama be told I think that the
metamodernism of Lord Miller is unique
to itself they are somehow always just
ahead of the curve they are futurists
with comedy they're able to know what's
about to be funny and they really change
the game with comedy over and over again
and I think that if that Trend hopefully
follows suit that's about to happen with
sincere drama this movie is so
sincere and honest and beautiful and
heartfelt and even in the the slow
patient moments it it lets it breathe
and I think that's the beauty of this
film is that for example uh spider-gwen
she's in the trailers you know she's in
the first movie she's very much in this
movie She's the co-lead of this movie
almost as much as miles in the screen
time and the artist who I think of with
spider Gwen is Jason latore Jason latore
is this incredible painted style and the
film lets the Jason LaTour art shape
that whole world but the thing about the
Jason LaTour art is that it uh it kind
of expands and breathes horizontally and
every time you're in her world it it
feels that expanding emotion right and
then like Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099
he's from the future and rickly and
already the most iconic in my opinion
most iconic Spider-Man 299 artist his
art always feels like it's not quite
Complete because it's in the future and
like it's not quite finished in in a
very conscious way the future's not
written yet Miguel's got these beautiful
accents around his face and he's got
these shapes that are like he's not
quite there and all of that's very
intentional and it's all a love letter
to the art that reflects these
characters and that isn't just for nerds
for me but it's for the story it ties
into the story they're telling also the
way they shape the world I've talked
about uh LaTour I've talked about
Leonardi but the actual worlds
themselves there's a lot of really
interesting things where this is
gloriously spider-versal and the way
they shape even the worlds around the
characters also reflects the characters
and it's interesting because it's this
nature nurture thing right like
you are your environment and you know we
can't really live in these worlds for
too long but what we can do is if you
know the character and you love the
character that's the environment so
subconsciously your brain is like Well
yeah if it makes sense they'd be like
that but if you actually think about how
people are shaped and formed it's so
cool to actually see their environments
and how the world they came from
informed them and that just builds the
character two-fold and I thought they
handled all of those broad ideas really
well this masterfully handles some very
broad Concepts while delivering much
like the first film in quantum physics
this film delivers a lot of nature
nurture where you come from interesting
things about belonging and and what we
are and man Spider-Man movie and
then you've got like these amazing
supporting characters I mean obviously
in the first one we loved Spider-Man
Noir and Peter Porker but in this one
there's there's so much interesting
storytelling that I do not want to give
away I'm very excited for the spoiler
review but the reason behind some things
is tied directly into these supporting
characters and they are hilarious you
guys know Ben Reilly's in it and he is
one of my favorite characters and they
don't
they know how to utilize him in a very
unique way and then they also have uh
Spiderman India and in a very unique
setting and really really tie the story
beautifully to him and there's still so
many surprises this film has Far and
Away I think
yeah it has my favorite Cameo this film
has my favorite Cameo of all time and
it's really unique to my sensibilities
and I don't want to give too much away
in saying even anything more than that
but when I can talk about it it's the
Cameo I'm most excited to talk about
because it actually kind of looks at
some of my Cameo problems like it it
solves some of my issues with cameos and
it's so ambitious and so insane and it's
it's really wonderful and and once again
when I can talk about it it beautifully
summarizes why I love this film so much
and why I love Lord and Miller's love
for Spider-man and so
the movie itself is paced for adults it
is a drama it is at times very very
introspective but
it's got so much levity and so much
comedy it's never heavy in a way that
feels like a hindrance it's heavy and
it's thematic elements it's heavy in
some of it's storytelling but it's like
I said the metamodernism of drama it's
so self-aware in in its in its story and
it's drama but I hope that sincerity is
what we get out of this film because
it it's made for adults but kids could
learn so much from this story like how
you wear the mask is so important and
and what you do in these moments is so
important and I think the first film
really was a cultural shift and I think
this one has that same potential and to
be honest
they're so
such a bigger story like I love stories
about family and I love stories that
involve power and responsibility that's
why Spider-Man's my guy but so often
they feel like they've been told they so
often feel like uh you know you're
coloring by numbers and this one I I was
surprised at so many twists and turns I
mean not just the the obvious stuff like
you know your Easter eggs and your
cameos in those moments but genuine
storytelling turns surprised me because
it's it's
it's such a beautiful new story to tell
and by the time you're at the end
I didn't want this movie to end and it's
over two hours and I just wanted to live
in this world I wanted to experience
this world and the chemistry these
actors and shamik Moore is even more
Miles Morales he's even more uh just the
the this this man this this young man
who's coming into his own and Haley
steinfeld's chemistry with shamique is
incredible and this is maybe my favorite
take ever on spider Gwen like I love
spider Gwen in the comics and a huge fan
of spider-gwen but there's something
about the way she plays her that it
takes all the elements of Gwen that I
like and makes me love them and it adds
more there's this beautiful
hard innocence there's this beautiful
freedom but you you understand why some
of the choices you're like disagreeing
with she would make and it's really well
done and once again miles's father
steals every scene for me I love Brian
Tyree Henry brings to this character I
love Jeffrey the mom here gets a lot
more time to play uh Mrs Morales and she
is so the heart of this film
I I cannot wait to give spoilers on this
but it is very much the sequel I needed
it to be but it's more different than I
expected I'm glad the marketing didn't
give too much away I'm glad the movie
itself trusted me and I think most of
all I'm glad that Spider-Man being so
Universal so multifaceted allowed the
movie to keep surprising me even as a
Spider-Man fan because there's things
that happen in the comic books that
happen in the film but then they like
play with those so their story elements
you'll recognize but then they add
layers onto it and
and to be honest this is bordering on
spoiler but this is everything I wanted
Multiverse of Madness to be this is
everything I want
this new sub-genre of multiversal impact
to be it lands all of the swings the
other movies have tried this is the
everything everywhere all at once
Spider-Man and
I'm in love with it it is so very good
it is so very special it's Spider-Man
and uh
yeah I think this is my new favorite
Spider-Man movie and that's saying a lot
Easter eggs cameos all of the things you
could want in that uh you know more
modern uh people look for it in their in
their clip out videos but in the more
traditional sense of Storytelling it is
every bit the drama every bit The Love
Letter to love and family every bit the
laugh a minute cry a minute later comedy
drama
just just love letter to Spider-Man that
I wanted it to be I'm uh I'm happy to
report
five stars a plus across the spider
versus everything Lord Miller he did it
again thank you thank you thank you for
taking such good care of these
characters I love so much I cannot wait
to see it again leave a comment below
let me know which character you're most
excited to see let me know who you're
most excited to see debut or who you're
most excited to see return let me know
in the comments below once you've seen
it who your favorite character was which
World which artist I just
this movie
foreign